In the battle against Thanos, the day was
ultimately won by a tiny, unlikely hero.
No, not that one, but you're close.
During a spoiler filled interview with a Chinese
website, Avengers: Endgame co-director Joe
Russo let slip the true hero of the film,
though if you're anything like us, it had
probably already crossed your mind that the
Avengers victory would never have been possible
if not for... a random mouse.
Of course, the key to the Avengers' eventual
victory was actually Scott Lang.
He was last seen in the post-credits scene
for Ant-Man and the Wasp, stranded in the
Quantum Realm after Hank Pym, Janet Van Dyne,
and Hope Van Dyne… who were to pull him
out once he was finished collecting "healing
particles" for their new friend Ghost… were
all dusted before they could throw the switch
and bring Scott back.
At the start of Endgame, we learn that during
the five years since the Snappening, the van
in which the Quantum Tunnel was housed had
been sitting in a rodent-infested storage.
In a 14-million-to-one shot, one of those
rodents just happened to crawl across the
exact right spot on the Tunnel's control panel,
zapping Scott back into the world.
"I went forward in time to view alternate
futures."
"How many did you see?"
"14 million, six hundred and five."
"How many did we win?"
"One."
This raises the question: if not for that
mouse, would Thanos have won?
If it would have crawled across a different
portion of the panel, even, would the Avengers
have been hosed?
According to Russo, the answer is yes.
"The mouse saved the universe.
Among the many realities in those 14 million
possible futures Doctor Strange [foresaw],
the mouse failed to press the button and thus
the heroes failed in those futures."
That's… just insane.
Yes, the Avengers' plan to reverse the Decimation
was a convoluted one, with different teams
traveling to different time periods in order
to pre-emptively acquire all six Infinity
Stones before Thanos could get his hands on
them.
It was also fraught with complications: Tony
Stark and Steve Rogers failed to grab the
Tesseract during the Battle of New York, necessitating
a slight detour to 1970; like Gamora before
her, Black Widow was forced to give her life
in exchange for the Soul Stone; and 2014 Thanos
figured out the whole plan due to Nebula's
incursion into that period, almost managing
to thwart our heroes by sending the still-villainous
past version of Nebula to the present as a
mole.
But since we know that Doctor Strange saw
the only outcome that resulted in victory
during his future-viewing party on Titan during
Avengers: Infinity War, we know that somehow,
it all played out exactly like it was supposed
to… and that included the contribution of
that low-down, dirty mouse.
Think about what must have been going through
Doctor Strange's mind when he handed the Time
Stone over to Thanos, knowing that the future
of the universe depended on the random wanderings
of a mouse five years in the future.
We suppose that one could take it even further,
making the case that the universe was really
saved by whatever anonymous towing company
employee decided to move Scott's van to that
crappy storage facility rather than a nicer,
non-vermin-infested one.
Or the security guard who let Scott out of
the locked facility, rather than calling the
cops on the wild-eyed stranger who had suddenly
appeared in said facility out of nowhere.
There were a lot of moving parts to the whole
thing, but in the end, we've got to go with
the word of Russo: a mouse was responsible
for half of all life in the universe being
restored, which we're sure has nothing to
do with the fact that Marvel Studios is owned
by Disney.
It's doubtful that Lang even knows exactly
how he was freed, which is a real shame, because
at the very least, that mouse deserves a medal.
Or perhaps an honorary membership in the Avengers?
So next time you think about the Avengers
saving the universe, remember: as much as
we all love Captain America and Iron Man,
"I only hope that we never lose sight of one
thing: that it was all started by a mouse."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Marvel
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.